buona sera io sono ilaria capo e sono un
veterinario pensate un po che cose che
capitano nella vita però non vi parlerò
di animali e per vostra fortuna non vi
parlerò neanche tanto di virus un
pochino perché in realtà io faccio il
virologo non ho quasi mai messo il
termometro nel sedere di un cane o di un
gatto perché fondamentalmente mi fa un
po schifo e vi parlerò di cambiamento e
vi parlerò di come bisogna aver voglia
di lasciare la vita precedente per
quello che potrete diventare io mi
occupo di di questi virus con cui non
vuole lavorare nessuno sono quelli per i
quali ci vuole l'elmetto i guanti il
mascherone sono questi virus che
spaventano spaventano molto l'opinione
pubblica e la comunità scientifica e per
parlarvi di questi virus però io ho
chiesto aiuto a una persona che si
chiama michelangelo che un uomo si però
insomma diciamo che era anche abbastanza
femminile e si vede e ho chiesto aiuto a
lui ho preso delle immagini della
cappella sistina
perché così magari ve ne andate a vedere
perché vi posso dire la cappella sistina
è una cosa spettacolare e queste
immagini vogliono essere in realtà degli
spunti di riflessione vogliono vogliono
fare vogliono aiutarmi ad aiutarvi a
riflettere punto numero 1 l'italia forma
talenti femminili nei forma tantissimi
le ragazze si laureano meglio si
laureano in tempi più brevi e ottengano
dei voti più alti e questo ha un costo
per lo stato
perché in questo paese l'istruzione
diciamo è gratuita ha un costo e
l'italia non può permettersi di non
utilizzare i migliori talenti che sforna
nei livelli dirigenziali più alti perché
voi capite che se no si va in perdita
bisogna recuperare questo costo un altro
spunto di riflessione è sull'ambizione
un uomo ambizioso
va bene una donna ambiziosa è mica tanto
ma questa sgomita ma cosa vuole ma mamma
insomma non va tanto bene e invece una
sana ambizione non ha nulla di male e
guardate questa immagine quasi michela
sono tornato indietro
guardate questa immagine di michelangelo
lui che c'è anche la tartaruga
sull'addome come potete vedere bello e
lei con la sua scala
no per per salire e lei che la scala c'è
l'acqua peng negli occhi non va bene non
va bene
vi voglio anche parlare di opportunità
di opportunità da cogliere perché le
opportunità passano l'abbiamo sentito
prima in questa sessione
io veramente ho sentito musica per le
mie orecchie le opportunità
passano però diciamo che l'opportunità
trova te ma tu pure e ti deve voltare
perché se le opportunità trovato e te e
tu sei girato dall'altra parte è diciamo
che non funziona così
quindi su diciamo utilizzando questi
quattro spunti di riflessione vi
racconterò un po della mia vita io io
spero che ecco allora io mi sono trovata
in giovane età a dover gestire il più
grosso focolaio di influenza aviaria che
si fosse mai verificato al mondo
l'influenza aviaria è
il virus più aggressivo che vi è nel
mondo animale uccide il 100 per cento
degli animali che infetta in 48 ore
e come il veleno è come il gas
a quei tempi parliamo del 99 2000
nessuno aveva avuto un epidemia del
genere non si era mai verificata e
soprattutto era vietato vaccinare
voi capite che per salvare la vita di
questi animali e per salvare un intero
comparto produttivo qualche cosa bisogna
anche fare eccola qua vedete giovane
giovane mi sono trovata in mezzo a
questo casino gigantesco e cosa abbiamo
fatto abbiamo lavorato lavorato giorno e
notte sabato domenica per gestire questa
epidemia gigantesca abbiamo studiato
tantissimo e abbiamo con una trovata
guardate il posto di pure una cosa
semplice
abbiamo sviluppato il primo sistema di
vaccinazione al mondo che permettesse da
un lato garantisce la salute degli
animali e dall'altro permettesse le
esportazioni dei prodotti
perché se tutta levy i polli e poi non
puoi commercializzare la carne mica ti
posso far compagnia ai polli ecco e
quindi era abbastanza importante e
questo sistema che è stato il primo a
essere utilizzato è andato a finire oggi
se voi prendete la legislazione
dell'unione europea su come si
gestiscono le malattie degli animali
vedete che c'è il nostro sistema di va
incluso nella legislazione europea
quindi una ragazzina come me era una
ragazzina ti fai venire in mente una
cosa che abbia un senso c'è il coraggio
di portarla avanti l'ambizione cogli
l'opportunità e il tuo sistema va a
finire nella legislazione europea ma di
più il vabbè ma questo
è questione di fortuna il non vedere che
arriva dopo allora cogliere
l'opportunità quando io ho cominciato a
lavorare in questo istituto eravamo un
gruppetto di persone voglio dire anche
che si volevano bene armati di buona
volontà
grazie a questa idea alla visibilità al
fatto di avere diciamo avuto scritto
progetti di ricerca eccetera eccetera
il gruppetto che la beve coca cola
festeggia un matrimonio è diventato un
gruppo leader a livello mondiale nella
proprio micro disciplina di riferimento
che ha attirato 12 milioni di euro in
cinque anni in italia per fare ricerca
in italia e abbiamo avuto il
riconoscimento delle organizzazioni
internazionali quindi ma siamo stati
bravi mele miei ragazzi sono stati bravi
ma bravi facciamogli un applauso ai miei
ragazzi bravi e meno bravi solo i
tedeschi
ritorniamo a michelangelo nella vita
ragazzi ci vuole coraggio ci vuole
grinta ci vuole anche saper
sfidare
le consuetudini andare contro quello che
sono i dogmi prima ho sentito parlare di
dogmi le persone magari anziane mature
che ti dicono ma no questo non lo puoi
fare questo non si può fare non si può
fare
michelangelo qui ha raffigurato bene
questa pure sembra che gli dà una sberla
al nonno qua allora parliamo di un altro
virus dell'aviaria
non ha importanza comunque l'h5n1 una
preoccupazione per la salute pubblica
internazionale questo virus nel 2003
parte dall'asia infetta tre continenti
non si era mai verificata prima una cosa
del genere
e noi eravamo a quell'epoca già un
laboratorio importante avevamo un sacco
di collaborazioni con con mezzo mondo è
però una del the consuetudini che
c'erano era che i ricercatori si
tenevano le informazioni relative ai
virus come tipo le impronte digitali
nascoste dentro un cassetto il che voi
capito non va tanto bene perché se tu
lavori per la salute pubblica che fai ti
tieni le informazioni dentro i cassetti
cioè bisogna lavorare insieme siamo non
siamo di fronte a un'epidemia il virus
arriva in africa e
e il nostro laboratorio è stato il primo
a isolare caratterizzare il virus
africano
quindi noi ci avevamo un tesoretto
ognuno già i tesori che vuole
noi diciamo sto virus che tutti stavano
a guardare studios e tutti volevano
sapere come era suo virus
e allora che cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo
sfidato la logica precostituita siamo
andati contro il sistema il mio
sostituto è stato il primo a isolare
questo virus africano abbiamo declinato
l'offerta dell'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità di depositare questo virus
in un database ad accesso limitato al
quale potevano avere accesso soltanto 15
laboratori e l'abbiamo messo in un
database ad accesso pubblico perché se
siamo di fronte a un'epidemia bisogna
che lavoriamo tutti insieme e questa
cosa
di fatto a io mi sono ficcato in un
pasticcio che neanche vi dico sono viva
per miracolo ma è venuto science che non
è che viene tanto spesso nei laboratori
italiani ma soprattutto abbiamo iniziato
un dibattito a livello internazionale
dove la comunità si è chiesta ma ma che
è sta storia che i ricercatori si
tengono i virus dentro i cassetti questo
sistema deve cambiare e infatti il
sistema è cambiato e oggi lo ms come
tante altre organizzazioni
internazionali promuove la trasparenza
dei dati la libera circolazione dei dati
e lo sapete perché è importante per
apple ha cioè se uno già un virus
mortale che sta in africa che può
prendere un aereo e venire in italia
vogliamo lavorare tutti insieme oppure
vogliamo stare a farci scusa questo non
te lo faccio vedere questo non te lo
faccio vedere e quindi di fatto abbiamo
determinato un cambiamento nelle
politiche sanitarie internazionali e
questo devo dire mia mi ha portato poi a
molta gloria e ho vinto un sacco di
premi questo scientific american 50
i 50 migliori ricercatori al mondo
stesso sbagliati ma no si sono sbagliati
no hanno sbagliato revolutionary minds
ma non vi pare a voi che ho fatto una
cosa normale a me pare però econome squa
vedete questo nel 2013 io non sono
quella col cappello rosso sono quella
col camice economy si dice questa sarà
una delle persone più influenti eccetera
per aver fatto una cosa che chiunque
avrebbe potuto fare e adesso arrivo alla
fine della mia presentazione e vi
racconterò una cosa che io e la prima
volta che racconto in italia e vi
parlerò di come bisogna evolversi e
bisogna cambiare bisogna trasformarsi e
michelangelo ci fa vedere le due
pettinature lo sguardo curioso della
della donna sinistra e anzi a destra vi
parlerò del cambiamento e il 6 gennaio
del 2013 non ve la facciamo questo corto
perché non abbiamo molto tempo ricevo un
sms da mario monti che io pensavo fosse
uno scherzo
cioè certi pare che questo manda un sms
a me il quale mi chiede se io volevo
candidarmi alle elezioni e riassumo
perché poi la cosa è stata abbastanza
buffa perché io non me lo sarei mai
aspettato
e così è stato io ho pensato noi siamo
sempre a lamentarci di questo nostro
paese dove le cose non funzionano e ti
viene chiesto di fare qualche cosa per
il tuo mondo da un altro punto di vista
e allora io gli ho detto di sì gli ho
detto di sì
da allora sono in parlamento metto mi
piace mettere questa è positiva perché
la foto è uscita sul match e c'è scritto
primo mini italia proprio mentre mario
monti a sinistra come se qualcuno
potesse pensare che il primo ministro
vabbè comunque al di là di questo mi
sono trovata sparata in parlamento io
che stavo lì a pasticciare come virus
fino alla settimana prima insomma
un'esperienza una grande cambiamento
però non è di questo che vi voglio
parlare io vi voglio parlare di questo
poco dopo la mia elezione in parlamento
ecco che cosa mi è successo questa è la
cosa più importante che io vi dico oggi
mi è successo questo ho fatto la
copertina dell'espresso ed è uscita una
notizia sul fatto che io fossi in realtà
non una scienziata ma una che nascondeva
i virus e le vendeva e trafficava in
virus eccetera eccetera
io non entro non voglio entrare nel
merito di questa cosa che mi ha travolto
ea mi ha colpito mi ha fatto soffrire
moltissimo
io voglio voglio dirvi che queste cose
succedono
se tu ragazze aprite bene le orecchie
se voi siete delle donne di successo
questo accade anche agli uomini successo
accade il fango arriva i messaggi che vi
voglio dare sono sono questi prima di
tutto la leadership e fatica tanto
lavoro fatica secondo implica
necessariamente che si vada contro
schemi consolidati nessuno nessuno
diventerà un leader se fai quello che è
stato fatto prima di te lo abbiamo
sentito prima
gli individui di successo anni hanno
molti nemici
ricordatevelo ricordatevelo subirete
attacchi subirete violenze subirete
maleducazione subirete offese e non
capirete perché perché attraverserete
momenti di grandissima gioia ma anche di
disperazione questi messaggi qui vedete
il mio branco di pesciolini sono i pesci
perché la cosa più importante che vi
voglio dire è che il dolore può
devastare può distruggere delle carriere
le può spezzare e perdere delle carriere
dei talenti perché il fango o le
difficoltà arrivano non è giusto e
quindi il vil pesciolino rosso della mia
relazione
il vero messaggio è questo che bisogna
essere residenti
bisogna rimettersi insieme i colpi duri
arrivano nella arrivano nella vita
privata arrivano nella vita pubblica
arrivano perché ti esponi arrivino
arrivano perché ti capita una sfortuna
arrivano ma questi sono in realtà delle
opportunità travestite perché questa
faccenda mi ha fatto ripensare a tante
cose della mia vita mi ha fatto
ripensare a a errori che ho fatto mi ha
fatto ripensare a a che cosa voglio fare
in futuro
e vi garantisco che per me questa sarà
stata un'opportunità e chiudo con questa
che è di lao tze ciò che il bruco chiama
la fine del mondo il resto del mondo
chiama farfalla
ricordatevi che cambiare cambiare è
soltanto un opportunità e si può
diventare più belli più forti più ricchi
e vivere con più gioia grazie